je vais vous parler des règles des
menstruations un phénomène connu de tous
et toutes
et pourtant il y a encore beaucoup de
choses à faire à apprendre et surtout à
déconstruire notamment des idées reçues
des superstitions des mythes des
croyances et des tables je vous propose
un petit voyage dans le temps dans
lequel nous serons confrontés à des
idées à des textes pour essayer de
comprendre comment les strates de
l'histoire sont parvenus jusqu'à nous et
comment
trop souvent nous sommes acteurs et
actrices du tabou des règles quand je
suis amené à parler de mes études sur
les règles à ma famille mes proches ou
des inconnus
je suis tout de suite confrontées à un
problème les mots la manière de dire les
règles le champ lexical tout de suite on
me dit ok tu parles d ragnagnas ou bien
mon interlocuteur ou mon interlocutrice
refusent simplement d'utiliser les
termes de menstrues menstruations ou
règles qui sont pourtant les trois terne
idéaux pour parler de ce phénomène
naturel et c'est vrai on en utilise on
en utilise des métaphores ou des
expressions il y aurait d'ailleurs 5000
manière de dire les règles à travers le
monde
en france on utilise surtout des
expressions liées à la couleur rouge
l'armée rouge
les anglais débarquent les fraises les
coquelicots
en fait c'est quelque chose que l'on
retrouve dans à peu près toutes les
cultures et à travers toutes les langues
les finlandais par exemple petite
variante parle de jours des framboises
les portugais de feu rouge
à cuba ils disent qu'ils sont
accompagnés qu'ils sont avec le petit
chaperon rouge à quoi ils servent au
final cette expression pourquoi on les
utilise autant est ce que ce serait pas
une manière de cacher une gêne est ce
que ce serait pas déjà le premier signe
d'une forme de tabou j'ai moi même
utiliser et j'utilise encore parfois
beaucoup d'expressions d expression que
je ne comprends pas toujours et que je
ne comprenais pas je suis indisposé
c'est pas la bonne semaine du mois ce
sont des expressions qui sont souvent en
plus péjorative peut-être que dire
simplement j'ai mes règles parler
simplement des règles ce serait un
premier pas pour dédramatiser ce
phénomène naturel et pour éviter surtout
d'en faire un table parce qu'il est
encore question de tabou une enquête de
2017 a montré qu'en france 44% des
femmes se sentent et honteuse pendant
leurs règles et que 43 % d'entre elles
se sentaient gênées lors de l'achat de
leur protection hygiénique mais il vient
d'où ça vous en faites pour répondre à
cette question il faut venir des siècles
en arrière voire des millénaires en
arrière et on peut prendre comme point
de départ les textes les trois grands
textes de nos religions monothéistes ces
textes disent à peu près tous la même
chose le sens des règles est un sang
impur par exemple dans le lévitique dans
l'ancien testament
il est clairement dit quand une femme a
ses règles elle est un pur et tout ce
qu'elle touche doit être purifiée
il y a aussi beaucoup d'interdits lie à
la sexualité c'est interdit ils sont
véhiculés par ces textes religieux mais
pas seulement ils sont aussi véhiculé
par les textes médicaux pendant des
siècles les médecins vont expliquer
qu'un enfant conçu pendant les règles de
viendra où les pr
boiteux ou bien encore dotés de grosses
taches rouges sur le corps ses textes
ses idées produisent cette notion de
sang impur produisent beaucoup
d'interdits lié aux règles encore
beaucoup ne font pas l'amour pendant les
règles
pourquoi par tradition peut-être on ne
sait pas encore beaucoup ne peuvent pas
accéder à un lieu de culte pendant leurs
règles encore trop de femmes ne peuvent
pas accéder à l'école pendant les règles
c'est interdit prennent la forme d'exil
menstruel par exemple au népal il ya une
tradition largement suivi et répandue
surtout dans les campagnes où une femme
doit habiter loin du village pendant ces
règles ces femmes habitent des petites
cahutes des petites huttes des cabanes
au confort très précaire et même si
cette tradition est interdite depuis
quelques années des femmes meurent
chaque année à cause de ses traditions
elles meurent intoxiquées par les fumées
car elle essaye de se réchauffer elmer
attaqué par des bêtes sauvages parce
qu'elles sont isolés du village le tabou
des règles à tuer et continue à tuer
cette notion d'impuretés on la connaît
souvent plus ou moins par contre qu'on a
oublié c'est que nos anciens nous ont
aussi donné une idée que le sang dans ce
trou n est un sens magique un sens
maléfique
l'auteur qui parle le mieux de cette
notion de sens maléfique
c'est certainement pline l'ancien un
auteur romain du 1er siècle alors pline
l'ancien il a écrit l'histoire naturelle
qui est en quelque sorte la somme des
connaissances de son temps dans cette
histoire naturelle
il raconte que le sang menstruel et le
pire des poisons que le sang menstruel
fait tomber les fruits des arbres que le
sens des règles stérilise les céréales
que le sens des règles tu les insectes
et si un chien venait à goûter ce sens
il deviendrait aussitôt en rage
alors ça peut nous paraître farfelue
d'un autre temps et pourtant jusqu'au
début du 20e siècle
certains médecins expliqué que dans le
sens d'entre elles il y avait une toxine
une toxine qui était tellement forte
qu'elle pouvait faire fans et un bouquet
de fleurs finalement le texte de pline
l'ancien est un petit peu le point de
départ entre beaucoup de croyances et de
superstitions qui relie le sang est
l'aliment vous connaissez toutes et tous
j'en suis sûr la tradition française
la superstition française qui veut
qu'une femme qui a ses règles ne peut
pas faire de mayonnaise
voilà vous connaissez eh bien on
retrouve ça dans d'autres cultures sous
d'autres formes
par exemple en argentine les pas
question de mayonnaise mais de blancs en
neige ses idées elle était présente dans
nos sociétés surtout dans les sociétés
rurales et populaires
quelques textes tradition orale montre
que jusqu'au début du 20e siècle
dans le limousin par exemple les femmes
n'avaient pas le droit d'approcher les
ruches on avait peur qu'elles tuent les
abeilles en anjou on envoyait les femmes
ayant leurs règles dans les champs pour
tuer les chenilles et donc nos anciens
les grands fondateurs ont estimé que le
sang était un pur que le sang et est
maléfique
mais le sens dans ce cruel c'est surtout
quelque chose de contrôle est
stigmatisée surveiller si on regarde
globalement la littérature médicale de
l'antiquité jusqu'au xxème siècle on
remarque quelque chose pour les médecins
le sens dans ce cruel c'est quelque
chose d'ambigu d'ambivalence à la fois
quelque chose de négatif en raison des
troubles des douleurs quelque chose qui
symbolise la féminité la fragilité mais
en même temps le sang menstruel et s'en
est nécessaire à la fertilité
nécessaires à la santé
d'ailleurs
il parle souvent de sang salvateur pour
beaucoup de ses médecins
la majorité des maladies féminine peut
s'expliquer par un arrêt des règles ou
l'ours ou lorsque le sang ne coule pas
assez du coup il faut faire couler le
sang pour qu'elle ne tombe pas malade et
pour faire revenir la santé une panel de
thérapie va être mis en place au fil des
siècles par exemple au 19e siècle au
xviiie
si vous étiez des classes bourgeoises ou
aristocratiques de la société votre
médecin pouvait vous préconiser
certaines activités comme la danse ou
l'équitation pour l'idée de faire
mouvoir le corps est de faire venir et
plus abondamment les règles ils
pouvaient aussi vous prescrire certaines
eaux minérales ou un régime diététique
particulier et puis si le sang ne
coulait pas il fallait le faire couler
coûte que coûte même artificiellement
alors on usait des saignées on
appliquait des ventouses sur les cuisses
et pire encore on appliquait des
sangsues parfois même sur la vulve ses
idées elles ont eu du poids
elles ont du poids sur ce que ressentent
les femmes et elles ont encore du poids
aujourd'hui pendant des siècles nous a
dit une femme à partir de la puberté
ça doit saigné pendant des siècles on
nous a dit les règles ça fait mal c'est
normal non ce n'est pas normal
non ce n'est pas normal mais ça pose un
véritable problème de santé publique
on pourrait diagnostiquer plus
facilement certaines maladies sion
prenez en compte la douleur des femmes
notamment l'endométriose une femme sur
dix en france seraient attendre
d'endométriose cela cause des graves
problèmes et de l'infertilité et si on
écoutait les femmes
et si on s'écoute et nous on arriverait
à en parler plus facilement
on pourrait diagnostiquer ces maladies
les choses sont en train de changer en
france depuis quelques années on a
beaucoup plus d'informations sur les
règles des formes d'éducation qui
prennent beaucoup de temps
d'ailleurs des livres des podcasts des
bd des associations les réseaux sociaux
beaucoup de pages instagram par exemple
qui valorise le sang qui coule en notes
entre nos jambes qui parle de tous ces
stéréotypes qui pèsent sur les femmes
aussi beaucoup d'associations qui vise à
lutter contre la précarité menstruel par
exemple car en france comme partout
ailleurs on ne devrait pas avoir à
choisir entre nourrir ou s'acheter une
boîte de tampon le discours se libère
par contre ce qui est plus difficile
c'est de se libérer des images et des
imaginaires notamment les images que
l'on voit tous les jours à la publicité
par exemple à travers la télévision
youtube dans le métro dans les magazines
tous les jours la publicité nous donne
des messages importants des messages
forts puissants pendant des années on
nous a vendu des serviettes parfumées
pour se sentir fraîche et élégante comme
si on était particulièrement répugnante
et odorante pendant nos règles pendant
des années on nous a vendu des
publicités avec des jeunes femmes
courant sur la plage en roller à la
piscine
bon les règles c'est aussi des fois être
affalé sur un canapé avec une bouillotte
pendant des années on nous a vendu des
applicateurs de tampons des toujours
plus petit plus discret pour les glisser
dans les poches dans les sacs à main et
surtout ne pas montrer comme si c'était
un civique totalement inciviques de
montrer de laisser apercevoir un bout de
protection hygiénique et surtout pendant
des années on nous a montré un liquide
bleu sur nos serviettes hygiéniques pour
montrer l'efficacité d'absorption de
telle ou telle marque un liquide bleu
moi j'ai grandi avec ces images
bizarrement ça m'a pas choqué j'ai
toujours été habitué à voir ça mais à
quoi il sert ce liquide bleu ce que ce
serait pas une forme de censure
est-ce que ce liquide bleu ne
permettrait pas de faire des règles un
tabou en 2018 les français ont pu voir
le premier spot publicitaire montrant un
liquide rouge sur les serviettes
hygiéniques d'abord sur internet puis un
an après à la télévision
ils ont été profondément choqués pour la
plupart d'entre eux beaucoup de plaintes
beaucoup de pétitions auprès du csa
mais c'est bien les choses bougent il ya
encore un long chemin à faire un long
chemin à faire pour qu'on soit fiers de
nos règles et pour qu'il n'y ait plus du
tout de table on peut tous et tout agir
déjà en prenant en compte le bagagiste
aurait historiques et culturelles en se
déchargeant de ces imaginaires de ses
idées reçues vieille de plusieurs
milliers d'années parfois et surtout en
communiquant montrons les gays les
règles parlons des règles parlons-en
avec des mots simples
disons fièrement j'ai mes règles
cela permettra de désacraliser et
d'arrêter d'en faire un tabou pour notre
génération et les générations futures
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]